entre les 27 juin et le 6 juillet il y a
eu de très nombreuses dégradations des
violences très fortes dans ce pays et
nous les avons quasiment unanimement
condamnée je regrette que quelques amis
de Monsieur Mélenchon ne l'ai pas fait
ces violences et faisaient suite vous le
savez à la mort du sujet de Naël et
c'est violent elles ont touché des
symboles de la république des écoles des
bibliothèques des mairies même un bus
médicalisé c'est violence sont
inacceptables parce que elles sont le
fait de certains qui veulent le chaos
mais il n'y a pas de place pour le chaos
alors Monsieur le Ministre j'ai été
également indigné de voir que le
week-end dernier des députés insoumis
étaient présents à une manifestation
interdite parce que lorsqu'on vote la
loi en semaine on la respecte le
week-end alors monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre il s'agit
maintenant de reconstruire ces symboles
de la république de faire en sorte que
ces bâtiments publics ces lieux
d'accueil on soit capable demain de
montrer que c'est pas l'impuissance que
tu as rendez-vous mieux au contraire
l'efficacité calories vous faire en
matière d'urbanisme pour simplifier des
procédures qu'allez-vous faire en
matière de financement pour les
fluidifier qu'allez-vous faire en
matière de règles de marché public pour
rendre possible ce qui est nécessaire
car l'urgence est là sans oublier les
copropriétés où on est souvent réduit à
l'impuissance monsieur le ministre
d'ailleurs ce texte ce qui est important
c'est de montrer que la République est
là que la République ne lâchera pas
qu'il n'y a pas de place pour le chaos
et que cette république elle exige que
chacun respecte les lois et que chacun
aide celles et ceux qui comme les mers
sont en première ligne et ont été
exemplaires comme le soulignant encore
le président Materi la semaine dernière
j'attends vos réponses merci monsieur le
ministre